it's a fresh start for obeyed in Kabul
the German government gave him five
hundred euros and he's invested the
money in a small shop three months ago
he returned to Afghanistan where he was
born but where he now feels like a
stranger nothing fun so life here is
difficult for me because I was in
Germany where everyone is on time
zindagi but here in Afghanistan nobody
cares I really regret coming back obaid
originally fled afghanistan with his
brother they paid traffic as eight
thousand euros he now owns around 10
euros a day but he says the worst thing
about coming back is the almost daily
terror attacks his brother stayed in
Europe obeyed returned because he
couldn't leave his beloved sister alone
any longer when he was in Germany he
only learned a few words of German on
the streets he was never offered a
language class although he lived near
Frankfurt for a year he says he wanted
to integrate but couldn't still leaving
was hard hot the night of those two kids
I my dog at the airport I started crying
and the police asked me if I really
wanted to return to Afghanistan I said
yes I have to Bali mommy find what am I
honestly I was really happy that both my
brothers had made it to Germany but I
was sad too I felt very lonely and I
cried a lot I thought I'd never see my
brothers again for many returnees the
most vivid memories of Germany involved
bureaucracy mokhtar facil also fled to
Europe via Turkey and the Balkan route
paying traffic is over 5,000 euros a
dangerous journey the throne was thought
that people told me I'd get a house in
Germany and find work amid uu but it
wasn't like that at all oh I lived in a
really remote area cheers was more kiss
and after mocked I ended up in the state
of Brandenburg far from any urban center
he'd hoped his wife would be allowed to
join him or that he did least be able to
send money back to his family
maybe a religion as I thought at some
point I'd get a passport and would be
able to help my family in Afghanistan
and I'd be able to go to school in
Germany they don't love it them mokhtar
lasted nine months before returning
frustrated to Kabul he hasn't found a
job here either unemployment is rampant
the EU wants to send around 80,000
Afghans home to a country that even
according to its own government is
plagued by war and terrorism yeah on
what time in 2015 Germany said that
refugees could come so a lot of Afghans
sold everything they had and if they're
deported now it's a big problem for us
Afghanistan is overwhelmed something
evident every morning here in eastern
Kabul around seven thousand refugees are
returning from Pakistan every day many
of these people fled decades ago around
three million afghans still live in the
neighboring country many were born in
Pakistan and are now in their homeland
for the first time like 21 year old
Nia's then we go we have a lot of
problems we're living with relatives
because we have no house hopefully we'll
find one soon but most of all we weren't
fees the government doesn't have the
means to help these people who left
everything behind years ago
so the UN has stepped in most refugees
come here first returnees are given four
hundred dollars a piece on average to
get started not just Nia's and his wife
but the two children as well he's glad
to get it but knows it won't suffice
where's the dollarama is he I dream of
the day when I won't be dependent on
help like this get up I want peace
security and an education for my
children I can't read or write but I
want them to learn around a million
dollars are handed out in Kabul every
day an untenable situation they simply
won't be enough for all of Afghanistan's
far-flung refugees they have to start
again from scratch for most Afghans it
won't be the first time and probably not
the last obeyed often feels unhappy
about coming back to Kabul so he's come
to a decision my bedroom wall on I'm
going back to germany deutschland
fascinators hatred that no one's gonna
stop many sure than I lied ohne ende I'm
taking my sister with math Amos even if
they make it there's not much chance
they'd be allowed to stay anyway but
hope springs eternal
you